a couple tough questions but Catherine
you did posts on your Instagram about
something that is kind of rockin
bachelor nation right now you said look
I was a token diversity casting on my
season and I just wondered you know it
what did it feel like for you to write
those words was that something you'd
been thinking for a while and had never
just said publicly and how did that feel
for you well I think it wasn't like a
revelation that I had I think going into
it I knew well they have spots to bill
and they and that's not nothing against
casting you a wonderful job every season
after season they know what they're
doing they cast for the lead and then
they cast for the show
um and I was lucky to be one of the
people that was chosen I get to
represent you know the minority group
and I was happy too I think that that
might have like a negative connotation
to it where they have spots to build but
I think that they did a really good job
in our season to cast for Sean because
he actually has dated and has been
attracted to people that are from all
different walks of life all different
looks and I'm glad that I got to
represent
Filipinos and people of color on a show
that usually airs toured a lot of white
people it wasn't hard to write that I
think that it definitely made me think
about how I counted myself out as a
person of color because of what I
thought Sean would like and I didn't
know I just thought okay he's a
beautiful blonde nice boy from Texas on
paper we couldn't be more different so I
kind of already was like he's not gonna
pick me so I'm gonna have fun and I'm
gonna have a good experience but you
know that wasn't obviously the only
reason I was there there was a lot of
other reasons why I was I was
appreciative of being selected to be on
the show and I'm just glad that I got to
represent minorities
well Rachel Lindsay's talked about it a
lot I don't know if you guys saw what
she said today but she said that she
needs to acknowledge the systemic racism
in the franchise
she says that the show needs to cast
leaves that are interested in dating
outside of their race she said
specifically that the show needs to
diversify the producers
you were on the show and also that the
show needs to stop giving people of
color problematic storylines so I
wondered what you guys thought of that
and that that's a lot to take in I don't
know if you've seen her comments that's
that's heavy I I definitely didn't
really think about the diversity and the
producers that's fair I would say I want
to see a black bachelor right but I
think you would be doing that person and
injustice if you just cast them as the
lead for the simple fact that you want a
black bachelor so what they need to do
is start casting more black men in the
Bachelorette because they do the
recycling of you know vets Loretta
bachelor and then pick a good bachelor
based on their merits based on the the
fan reaction and so forth and it won't
be that difficult if you just continue
casting black men but unfortunately you
know season after season there only
seems to be one or two maybe three
casting approved for 25 but I think it
is fair that she needs to that that they
should find people that are truly
interested in dating out of the race I
mean again that's what Shawn Shawn came
in having i beliee know um you know
prejudice on what he wanted in a wife
besides kindness and having a best
friend all these different factors in it
just whatever the way that she looks you
know I'm happy for it so I think that
that's a fair thing to say is making
sure that you vet your your leads on if
they are truly into other reasons is
that a question that's asked of you
Shawn where you asked have you dated oh
yeah they asked me very specifically you
know what what type of woman are you
into and of course I started out with
you know I just want someone that's kind
it's funny and they said well no
physically what are you into and I I
said I really don't have you know I
don't have a type in and I told them you
know I've dated people of all races and
kind of went down that road with them
and I think that actually got them
excited and that's why there was
probably more diversity on my season
because they knew I was open to that but
yeah hopefully that trend continues and
they can continue finding leads who are
into
multiple per case but it also starts
with the contestant right he's not
coming from outside and just going in
it's okay if I were chosen as the
Bachelorette I would have already been a
contestant they should have asked me
those questions well and they didn't ask
me I was just like she was my type and I
haven't talked about anybody else
because they want somebody that's
generally interested in the lead so it's
kind of going to be a cycle like that
[Music]